it's like a fall operation it seems that
way nearly 10 000 vehicle thefts in
Metro's jurisdiction this year alone I
called my wife I was like please tell me
you're playing a joke on me with
catalytic converter thefts On The Rise
Barry Cotner says his mobile mechanic
business is thriving ending each day by
parking the car with thousands of
dollars worth of tools right outside his
door until Thursday morning waking up to
find his livelihood missing
the moment of realization just hours
before the same doorbell camera shows
the truck parked at 4 20 then gone by 4
30. there's no it's a plastic or
anything where they would have broken
into the door so ever did it they knew
what they were doing Cotner just began
his mobile mechanic business six months
ago with the truck his father used to do
the same work he since outfitted it for
daily travel across the valley I have no
backup it's just me taking care of my
family and without my truck
I can't make any money I can't pay my
bills the tools inside estimated at
twenty thousand dollars something he
says insurance doesn't cover all ahead
of a holiday weekend that's why I was
really hoping I would hear back
yesterday or today because I think the
farther carries on into the holidays the
less I think it's likelihood that
anybody's going to be really looking
leaving an uncertain future for both the
Cotner business and family just dump it
somewhere
bring it back
whatever you've stolen already
I'll forgive I just I need my truck
to pay my bills
he needs his truck to work now please
take another look if you see the truck
call police Crime Stoppers you can
remain anonymous he just wants his truck
back
702-385-55 Metro Police say vehicle
thefts up nearly 20 percent from last
year most of those thefts occurred in
the East Valley with a reported 1300
stolen Motor Vehicles